NBA analyst for ESPN and ESPN radio back
here on the show how are you John will
you say rich I'm glad to hear my Niners
are gonna be back on the map according
to everybody well John they are back
they are so back on the map right now
with GOG I mean having never lost but
you know with Kyle Shanahan having a one
year under his belt Jerick McKinnon I
thought was a tremendous pick up in the
free agency period they are who do we we
hear William beat many teams that were
all that great last year if I'm not
mistaken no you'd beat Jacksonville I
mean you beat Jacksonville in in in
Santa and you know in Santa Clara so
right that was a big one nobody so now
is that your team based on on what your
your bay area living days is that well
that's where I grew up sure okay I got
it
all right so tell me how the Warriors
get beat John give that recipe to me
here oh well they show up like they did
in Game three where it's basically just
their mental focus because when they're
going I don't think anybody beats them
as great a years houston has had I still
think if steps healthy and and they got
it cranked up their their that seem to
be do good so you're saying if as long
as they're mentally sharp nobody beats
them they're gonna raise the trophy
again this year yeah I think so I mean
you know what they play defense and
they're focused in on that end as you
saw yesterday completely locked up New
Orleans in that first quarter and then
with all the weapons they have I mean
they've incorporated chemic of on Looney
as a guy that's going to play a big
impact I mean the rookie Jordan Bell is
gonna play a little bit because they're
gonna match up with capela who's more of
a mobile type Center he's not a back to
the basket players so they can play some
more athletic guys with capela and I
think they're gonna give you some
problems I really do believe that so
when it all comes down to and it's
Houston is one win away from the Western
Conference Finals at home against Utah
and then that is new territory for Chris
Paul so you can get that removed from
his resume how do you think they are
preparing for the Warriors
right now well I mean they feel pretty
good they beat them two out of three in
the regular season beat them on opening
night and they feel like this is a
different group obviously a tremendous
season they're much better defensively
you bring in PJ Tucker Luke ba moot a
should be healthy and ready to go so
they feel like they can do it on the
defensive end that's really been what
has separated the two teams that Houston
was not good enough to play championship
level defense they feel like they can do
that now and they're gonna have to do
with the Warriors I mean look it could
be a great great series there's no doubt
about it it's going to be up and down a
lot of great offense and it really will
come down to you who can get enough
stops and I think at the end of the day
the Warriors are better defensive team
what do you make of the news that dream
on Green sent a motivational 4 a.m. text
to Kevin Durant John I don't know
draymond Green man he's out there isn't
he he's getting death threats and son-in
texted 4:00 in the morning wants to
punch or get punched by Charles Barkley
I mean he's got it going on but hey look
John the police who was that guy that
that that played that role on your on
your team's
yeah well you know I did I played with
Vern Maxwell a member of our max lowers
burn was a guy that they called him Mad
Max and everything was all hunky-dory
and all of a sudden Mad Max would think
he had to be Mad Max so he spit on a
coach or spit on the floor or do
whatever you need I mean you need that
no no no obviously but what you need you
need to have that guy who's gonna puff
his chest out and and and get in
somebody else's face certainly when
every I mean everybody else on the
Warriors is is like a sweetheart when
you think well I would say I think Kevin
Durant's a little different guy he's got
a little streak to them and Steph Curry
doesn't in a different way but yeah you
do need a guy that's kind of the pulse
in your team look at Marcus smart in
Boston I mean this guy he's definitely
the heart and soul that team he
when you see guys play that hard diving
on the floor and doing all the dirty
work things it can only help team Marcus
March that guy - all right so before we
you know get your thoughts on the
Eastern Conference which team he thinks
got the higher ceiling right now that's
about to go out New Orleans or Utah I
think New Orleans is in a great spot you
know they they they have the guy to ad
you know now Donovan Mitchell's
certainly had an unbelievable season but
I put a lot a lot of stock into Anthony
Davis and they got some calves because I
don't think they're gonna resign
boogy cousins and they go out and get
another player I think they could be a
very dangerous team and the Celtics what
what do you see in them that that can
actually continue whatever crazy run
that they're on right now John and make
this even more special than it seems to
be blossoming yeah it's an incredible
run I mean I thought when Kyrie was
announced to be done for the year that
they would had a hard time when in one
series let alone two and Brad Stevens
you can argue is the second best coach
in the NBA behind Gregg Popovich I mean
he's a mastermind the plays he runs side
out of bounds and putting these guys in
position to succeed and having the
belief that they can do that without
their best player amazing I still you
know I said Cleveland before this
started and I mean I don't know who
stops with bran James with the stuff
this guy's doing right now it's just
incredible I was here the other night
for the game-winner I was in Toronto
when he went for forty three just never
seen a superstar player be better at his
15th year that he was he being his
eighth or ninth or tenth year it's
incredible well I mean you're already
hearing the comparisons for Jordan etc
etc John where do you stand on that
subject yeah I'm gonna leave that alone
I mean I'm not going there yet still
Michael's the greatest ever and uh but I
think we we need to start appreciating
what this guys doing
if he can get another team eight years
in a row the finals uh it's remarkable I
just uh I've never seen an athlete I
mean
the best athlete to ever play the game
that's for sure and an ultimate teammate
brings the level of his team to
championship level and he's incredible
there's no doubt about it well why do
you think he doesn't get the credit
that's sometimes I don't know I guess
because it just because it's right now
it's going on now isn't everything you
know after time when you look back
things are better than they were when
you're living it I mean I guess I maybe
in ten years when he's done we say oh
geez remember what he did that year and
that year and every year do you think
he's going to play till he's 40
do you think he's 33 right so seven more
years with him at 22 years in the league
well if there's anybody can do it I mean
you look at his body right he's got a
shot what Kobe did 20 I think he'd be
hard-pressed to do that I don't think
he's going to do that but monaster all
right then let's fast-forward to the
absolute crazy scenario that could
actually play out which is Golden State
versus these calves again
how does LeBron pull it off do you think
he can trap Brown for I I just don't I
don't see he thought he could do that I
really don't see it look a little bit of
this as a product of a poor Eastern
Conference let's be honest
Toronto 159 games they were number one
in the East and they're about to get
swept they played an Indiana team that
traded their all-star they had Victor
Oladipo an incredible season but they go
seven games with them I mean you see
Philly they're not they're not playoff
ready they're gonna get swept more than
likely tonight gets Boston Cleveland
will watch through bots Boston I think
they'll win that series in five games
and then they're gonna get to either
Houston or Golden State whoever you
might think it might be I don't think
the LeBron can be tired of those teams
so the Western Conference Finals is the
de-facto Finals is what you're saying
that's what I would say love our chats
John where have I found you I heard some
honking of the wardens in the Bell I'm
just walking the streets of Cleveland
it's actually pretty nice huh okay
walking the streets of Cleveland
to the street okay and and your and your
and your call of the game this evening
you'll be there if i have the game i
have the game tonight on ESPN radio
Kevin Calabro is joining Kevin I love
him man is it the best pipes ever
I just eased I miss his call on the
Sonics oh yeah no no kid gotta get a
team back there don't we I agree do you
have any history in in Seattle at all
John I lived in Mercer Island for two
two years beautiful spot alright John
have a great call tonight with Kevin
Calabro have a great call okay rich you
got it we'll chat again soon that's John
Barry the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience